[موسيقى]
الحرب لا تنفذ حربا مؤلمة طويلة نحن
نحن ندفع أسعارًا باهظة كل يوم، للأسف، ولكن هذا السعر
حرب من أجل وجود دولة إسرائيل و
بقائها وحقنا في العيش
أعتقد أن الأمة بأكملها متحدة بشأن هذه المسألة، وأعتقد ذلك
أن قضية الوحدة هي الشيء الرئيسي الذي يجب التعامل معه اليوم
أنه بعد التكوين الذي يتعاملون معه، لم يعد لدي
مشكلة المبادئ صحيحة لأنها في النهاية ضرورية
معرفة كيفية التخفيض هو أيضًا الجهد الحالي
الحرب في النهاية مستمدة من نوع ما من الأغراض
على المدى الطويل ولكن الإطار الذي يتم وضعه
اليوم يجب أن نبدأ مناقشة اليوم التالي للقول
تنهي الحرب وتذهب إلى العالم من بعدنا
بعيدة كل البعد عن إنهاء الحرب بالنصر
المشكلة الأولى هي أن المناقشة نفسها تنقل لي الضعف
بعزم واضح والذهاب على طول الطريق وتدمير
همس التي تجري جبهة الحرب تكتيكاتها
الحرب التي يمكنني التعايش معها عندما تأتي
لإدارة الآباء الاستراتيجيين من الناحية التاريخية
ويعقوب، ما يحدث اليوم في قطاع غزة هو حدث
التاريخية في ترتيب الكتاب المقدس وماذا وكيف تمكنا من ذلك
وفي غزة سوف يبث الكثير عن يهودا والسامرة إذا
سنذهب إلى أي مكان في الشمال في يهودا
والسامرة وأيضا عن إيران أقول لكم أيضا في سياقات
هجرة البوبو السياسية أو لا هجرة
في الأرض ثمن، ليس في الأرض ثمن لمن يتعامل
معنا نعم أنثى 48 67 23 سوف يشع هذا الشيء
لعقود من الزمن سمحت الدولة بهذه الأشياء
اللعنة لقد كذبت على المجتمع الذي ألهم الجزرة
قبل اللاما وفجأة النساء الذين يتذكرون هذا الشيء
ونتذكر ما كانت تتعامل معه هذه الحكومة قبل السبعة
في أكتوبر في جميع أنواع الأشياء، حتى اليوم أنا كذلك
أعدك مشاهدينا إذا سألتهم ما هو
السبب المحتمل أنهم لم يتمكنوا من إخبارك بالضبط
سوف يفهمون فقط عن السابع في أكتوبر
والأشهر الثلاثة الماضية كم كان ذلك غير ضروري
كان ضارًا مثل الهجوم والآن كل شيء
القصة التي تجدد نفسها من جديد والإلهة ضد الإلهة والثورة
المحاكمة
أنا ولين ويرمان أخبرك أن الأمر مثير أيضًا
هدف صغير على خلفية أن الأمور مثيرة للغاية
الذي نحن فيه الآن، وإذا كانت هناك حكومة
المسؤولة في إسرائيل ستقول كفى
مع هذا القزم، قالت الحكومة أنه كان chezim
كل هذا الإصلاح غير الضروري، من يحتاج إليه
على الإطلاق، لدينا حرب نحتاج إلى الفوز بها
نحن المختطفون الذين تم إجلاؤهم بحاجة إلى الاهتمام بالأمر بما فيه الكفاية
نحن نتحدث بالفعل عن قطاع غزة
لكننا في حملة متعددة الساحات بالفعل
لعدة أشهر لم نذكر يهودا على الإطلاق
والسامرة يهودا والسامرة منذ بداية الحرب
وتم القضاء على حوالي 500 من هذه المخاطر منذ بداية العام
حوالي 300 فقط منذ بداية الحرب العام الماضي على سبيل المثال
155 على مدار العام أكثر من 2500 كنز
ومن بين هؤلاء، يقول 1300 من نشطاء حماس أنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك
بالنسبة لنا في جدار ماجن، كان جدار ماجن بمثابة حرب
لغرض الموضوع وبالتالي عندما ننظر
قطاع غزة مهم بالنسبة لنا أن نصل إليه في النهاية
لآلية إنهاء ولكن مع نوع من البيان الحاسم
لا أريد أن أقول اعترافا أو انتصارا لأنه
بعد السابع من أكتوبر لم تعد كلمة النصر
غير مناسب على الإطلاق لهذا الحدث، ولكن نعم نحن كذلك
نحن بحاجة للوصول إلى نوع من اللاحقة، ربما الرأس
لعشي السنوار ربما أصيب بنوع من الإصابة
إخراجهم على الرغم من أنني لا أعتقد أنهم كذلك
سيوافقون، لكن هذا الشريط يشير إلى الشرق كله
المدرسة الثانوية وهذا سيؤدي أيضًا إلى التغيير تدريجيًا
القتال في مناطق أخرى في الشمال وفي الداخل
يهودا والسامرة وأيضا في الساحات الأخرى
إن بُعد قطاع غزة أمر أبعد من أن يكون حاسماً
الخمسة موجودون ونحن نبحث باستمرار عن النقطة
أرخميدس أو لانهيار همس أو لفهم
هامس شو يذهب إلى هناك وأريد أن أخبرك عنه
مجموعة من التقارير أجدها مثيرة للاهتمام في الشهر الماضي
التي تعطي لمحة عن تصور تصور الواقع
الجزء العلوي من لحم الخنزير ليس بالضرورة الواقع الموضوعي
لكن تصور الواقع كيف سنوار وآخرون
تراها تعطيك سبويلر صحيح ما يبثوا
يقولون الاستغاثة أول تقرير من رويترز
يرفض هامس الصفقة التي عرضت عليه وهو المسيطر
في قطاع غزة من ناحية والحرب سوف تتوقف أي
يعتقد هامس أن تسينر يعتقد أنه سينجو من القتال
أما في قطاع غزة فلا نستطيع جلبه
الإنجازات الاستراتيجية الهامة ليس من حيث
وليس المختطفون في جانب أسرة حماس مثل شيف
وبدون هذين الإنجازين، لا يمكن لإسرائيل أن تزدهر
سأذكر الثقب هنا، وهو مشكلة أخرى
هذه هي الطريقة التي تذهب بها